turning now to the supreme court where
the justices heard arguments over a
unique anti-abortion law in texas the
court must decide if the law can be
challenged in lower courts some of the
justices questioned the way the law was
enforced during oral presentations
yesterday jan crawford is at the supreme
court jan good morning well i mean good
morning nate you know these were some of
the most interesting arguments i have
ever covered i mean it was three hours
incredibly high stakes and it was like
being in the middle of this giant legal
rubik's cube almost you know they would
turn here and you think they had it
resolved with the questions they asked
but then they turned here because that
would raise a different problem i mean
no state has ever tried to do what texas
is doing here which is banning something
here you know abortion after about six
weeks that the supreme court has said is
protected under the constitution and
then they're saying well you know we
won't enforce it we'll we'll just let
private citizens file civil lawsuits in
state courts who enforce the law oh by
the way with damages of at least ten
thousand dollars i mean it was clear
that a majority of the justices did not
like it i mean even some of the
conservatives who recognize this law
could have an impact well beyond
abortion rights there was a real concern
that it would be a model for other
states to pass similar laws that could
target other constitutional rights you
know if the court would allow this law
as liberal justice elena kagan had put
it that would mean we would live in a
very different world a point that was
also made by conservative justice brett
kavanaugh
and it could be free speech rights it
could be free exercise of religion
rights it could be second amendment
rights
if this position is accepted here
now the court is not reconsidering roe
versus wade in this case but next month
is going to take up a different case
it's asking the justices to overturn roe
and allow mississippi's 15-week ban on
abortion tony
that's a big one we'll be watching that
jan thank you very much